hey Vsauce Michael here if you rearrange
the letters in William Shakespeare
you can spell here was I like a song in
the King James Bible in psalm 46 the
46th word is shake and the 46th word
from the bottom is sphere William
Shakespeare was 46 years old when the
King James Bible was completed is this
just a coincidence yes it is
given enough searching enough words
enough data you can eventually find and
should indeed expect all kinds of neat
coincidences it's just probability
here's another good example think of a
card any card value and suit okay got it
mentally focus on that card deliver it
to my brain using ESP whoa I got it
here it is amazing right now think of
another card are you ready okay it's
some well it's this one right one more
time
think of a card really think about it
and there it is impressed
probably not but approximately seven of
you might be easy there are only 52
cards if each card is equally likely to
be thought of I had a one in 52 chance
of guessing your card and about a 1 in
every 140,000 chance of doing so three
times in a row if say a million people
watched this video and play along after
three tries you could expect about seven
people to be left who had their imagined
card pulled by mean each time
except not more than seven actually
you see there's even more magic
happening here and by magic
I mean math when asked to arbitrarily
think of a card studies have shown that
people tend to think of certain cards
more often than others these are the
results from a study of a few hundred
people hearts are named a bit more often
than the other suits the three cards I
drew are the top three most often
thought of but would it be more amazing
if it actually was magic yes and no
obviously magic as a performance is
important it reminds us that being
stupefied and curious and humbled is fun
without a visceral reaction to the
unknown would we care to learn or study
or investigate but yet explanations
don't dull mystery they empower the
mystified explanations aren't ends
they're in trances the start of an
ability to use reassemble and reimagine
new things out of what you now know
here's a cool fact if you divide a deck
of cards exactly in half there will
always be the same number of red cards
in one half as there are black cards in
the other no matter how mixed up the
cards were before you began
it's not magic though it's just that
think of it this way half of the cards
in a deck are red so all the red cards
could fit in one deck half this means
that the number of cards in a half that
aren't red that is our black cards are
necessarily equal in number to the Reds
that must be in the other half knowing
this you can devise an even neater trick
like the really cool trick Matt Parker
just showed off on his channel which you
should subscribe to or like this one
take an easier to count number of cards
like say 10 and then place another 10
cards on top but face up have a friend
shuffle the whole mess however they wish
cuts
messy cuts riffle smooshing they just
can't cause any card to flip over then
ask them to hand you the pack and behind
your back even while blindfolded show
them that you can separate the deck into
two halves with the same number of
face-up cards every time over and over
again all you have to do is count out
ten cards the number of face-up cards in
one hand will equal the number of
facedown cards in the other flip one of
the packs over and all of its facedown
cards will turn into face-up ones tada
the face-up counts are now equal here's
another trick that shows off some neat
mathematical properties to help me with
this trick I've brought in Vanessa from
the YouTube channel braincraft it's an
awesome Channel please go check it out
but first check out this trick are you
ready I'm ready
we've got ten cards on the table five
diamonds and five clubs ace to five of
each go ahead and put the clubs on top
of the diamonds face up face up yep
alright now I am going to mix these
cards up alright and you were gonna use
your ESP abilities to get the cards
paired up at the end you ready okay I
want to mix these up take some off the
top moving to the bottom taking parts
from the bottom and just like I don't
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna cut these as
well let me know where you want to cut
them okay yeah there okay we'll cut the
cards there and I'm gonna take half of
what's here five cards and deal them
down one two three four five I'm gonna
set the other five right there now we
have two piles and it is your turn to
start swapping we got poor swaps you can
make and a swap involves taking the top
card and moving it to the bottom okay
alright now you can divvy up these four
swaps however you want you can do four
here you can do 2 & 2 1 & 3 whatever you
want okay I'll do three here
yeah interesting yeah right you do it
I'll do it one two three and then one
swap here good yes now we're left with
these two cards on top I'm gonna take
them off and set them right here now
three swaps all three okay it's your
choice
one two three and the top two cards I
will peel off and we'll set aside all
right now two swaps two here mm-hmm all
right one two once again the cards that
are on top get peeled off and set aside
one swap one here okay so I'll take
these away and we're left with two cards
will they be the same will they be a
match let's find out okay
whoa don't say okay yet because things
aren't okay if something magic just
happened we've got all of these cards we
set aside and yet they're all matches
both aces right there what are these
both fives you also matched up the
threes and of course the fours you're
welcome
thank you very much but not you Vanessa
you mathematics every time no matter how
your friend decided to swap matching
pairs will be together how well it's all
about cycles if you have some cards in a
particular order and you cut them
somewhere doesn't matter waiter you will
only change the positions of the
individual cards but not the sequence
the next card down will always be the
next card in order with the whole thing
wrapping back around it helps to think
of the order not as a tower but as a
clock now when the trick we just did
each cards match is always just five
cards away in the sequence
because five happens to also be the
number of cards in half the pack
dividing the pack in half leaves pairs
lined up no matter how we've cut the
deck in the trick however we added a bit
of extra confusion by dealing the top
half down onto the table one two three
four five this has the effect of
reversing its order now instead of
having the same position in each package
pairs have mirrored positions the number
of cards below any given card in the
bottom pack is the number above it in
the top pack this balance means that
swapping all the cards above a target in
the bottom pack leaves it on top and
swapping the number of cards below it
from the other pack leaves its match on
the other top of course the number of
cards above and below a target card in
the bottom pack is just the number of
all the other cards in that half which
is the total amount in each pack minus
one that's why with five cards in each
pack we started with four swaps then
after each pack had shrunk to four we
did three swaps as long as the total
number of swaps adds up to the pack
total minus 1
we'll have matching pairs on top you can
extend these facts about cyclical
sequences to other tricks of your own
imagining this is one of my favorite
tricks it comes from Peter Magowan on
the stem maths magic channel trick time
once again I'm joined by Vanessa from
brain craft and ace through five of
diamonds and ace through five of clubs
Vanessa could you please take the ACE
through five of diamonds and put them on
top of the clubs but flip them over so
they're facedown okay so we now have a
kind of messy little deck here where all
the black cards are face up and the Reds
are face down we're gonna mix these up a
lot we can even riffle shuffle this
riffle shuffle right kind of divide it
in half like this and then well it's
hard to do with a few cards and they do
a little you know yeah thank you
where would you like me to cut these
right there okay cool now there's
another way you can kind of mix up a
deal cards it's called the down over
deal goes like this one card goes down
the next goes over one goes down one
goes over down over down over down over
until you're done okay but now it's your
turn all right I'm gonna go two at a
time and you're gonna tell me whether
these first two cards should be dealt
down or should be turned over okay
down down what about these down down
over down over all right now let's go
four at a time
okay one two three four should these go
down or over over what about these four
down death and the final two now we can
do this as long as as often as you want
I can keep doing this we can do - we can
do four at a time how do you feel
let's do it once more and do two at a
time two time okay
down down down
down you're getting faster buff down
okay all right now I'm going to make two
little piles like a little book all
right one okay
now Vanessa should I close this book
like this or like this all right there
we go now you had completely free choice
here mm-hmm you made a lot of different
decisions somewhat arbitrarily but yet
like oil and water
the black and the red cards have
separated and only the Reds have face-up
I knew this would happen but it's not
because of magic it's because of math
here's how it works the red cards all
start out facedown the black cards
face-up no amount of cutting or rippling
will change the fact that Reds are
facedown and blacks are face-up but when
you down over Deal you cause every other
card to have its original facing
direction reversed down over down over
down over down over down over this
alternating sequence is maintained
through any number of cuts because it's
cyclical this is the key to the trick
because when we alternatively deal cards
into book halves one pile will contain
cards reversed by the down over deal the
other cards not reversed
depending on how you close the book
either all reversed carts are
unrehearsed or all unrehearsed cards are
reversed
either way the original division by
color comes back the swaps missed things
up by introducing an illusion of control
but in reality the swaps are what are
known as a hummer deal a swap flips the
facing direction of the cards you flip
but simultaneously moves them to the
correct category preserving the sequence
as long as you swap an even number of
cards the facing direction of all of
them is reversed but the positions they
wind up in are still correct
according to the sequence finally let's
end with something popular that also
sounds cool on the surface until you go
deeper understand it better and it winds
up being well even cooler the number of
different ways 52 cards can be arranged
there's obviously a lot the top card
could be any card
so there's 52 different possibilities
any remaining cards can follow so there
are 51 possibilities for the next card
54 the third spot 49 for the fourth and
so on multiplying all of these numbers
together gives us how many unique ways
fifty-two cards can be arranged 52
factorial is a gigantic amount so large
in fact every time you shuffle a deck of
cards
well smoosh it for a few minutes or
riffle at seven or more times
chances are you have put those playing
cards into an order that they have never
been in in the entire history of cards
or humans or the universe seriously this
is because 52 factorial is eight point
zero six five eight times ten to the
67th in comparison the observable
universe is only about 10 to the 18th
seconds old even if you had been
properly shuffling a deck every single
second since the universe began 13.7
billion years ago you still to this day
wouldn't have even come close to
assembling every arrangement possible
but even that doesn't paint the whole
picture of just how big 52 factorial is
scotch appeal wrote what in my opinion
are some of the most mind-boggling
visualizations of the size of 52
factorial imagine setting a timer to
count down 52 factorial seconds while
the timer runs stand on the equator and
wait one billion years
after a billion years have passed take a
single step forward and then wait
another billion years before taking a
second step and so on
once you have walked all the way around
the earth take a single drop of water
out of the Pacific Ocean that's five
hundredths of a milliliter and set it
aside now continue walking at a rate of
one step every billion years removing
one drop after every journey around the
entire Earth and by the time the Pacific
Ocean is completely empty
put a single sheet of paper on the
ground refill the ocean and keep going
until the stack of paper reaches the Sun
at that point how many seconds will be
left on the timer will it be zero a few
hundred a few billion no there will
still be eight times ten to the sixty
seven seconds left you have barely made
a dent if you start all over again and
do that whole thing a thousand more
times you will only be 1/3 of the way
done
luckily Scott has a great idea for how
to pass the rest of the time if you're
bored of paper and water and walking
instead he says deal yourself five cards
every billion years when you finally
deal yourself a royal flush buy a
lottery ticket if the ticket wins the
lottery throw a single grain of sand
into the Grand Canyon as soon as the
Grand Canyon is completely full of sand
remove one ounce of rock that's about 28
grams from Mount Everest
by the time Mount Everest is leveled
take a look at the clock this is what
will be left
do the whole Royal Flush lottery ticket
Grand Canyon Mount Everest thing 256
more times and then and only then will
your timer have reached zero that is how
big 52 factorial is it's pretty big but
now think about this the number of
possible people the number of different
humans there could be is well even
larger what that means is that even
though you will probably die most people
including possibly the smartest or
funniest or most annoying possible
person won't even get to die like you do
they won't even get to be born so I'm
glad you were and as always thanks for
watching